(kissing fingers) SOMEONE STOLE THE CAPTIONS
(kissing fingers intensifies)
(Kissing Fingers - Dj PewDiePie ReMix)
Oh!
Look at that handsome face!!
(blows kisses)
Nose is a little big
Why didn't we fix this in the final build?
Existor?
God damn it
(pewds initiating awesome photoshop skillz)
(we need to repair that nose)
(but lets not spend a lot of money)
(bug in the matrix)
(smiths are closing in)
Mmm!
Pewdiebot is here
Phase one of taking over the universe
Has been initiated!
Let me just say
First of all
A huge thanks to everyone
who checked out
and bought the bot
We-
I- I understand
That a lot of people
wanted this to be free
We wanted it to be free
but we realized-
That's going to be really hard
Because I love money
(fake barfs)
Because the server
Takes a lot of power
And if we open the hellgates to
everyone to try out the bot
It's just going to be a-
A- a- sh- shit storm
You've seen how Pokémon Go barely plays
It would had been a bad experience for everyone
But also!
I know people get upset
at me like
'He only cares about money!'
Yeah.
It costs money to make this sorta stuff
But regardless
I do wanna say
I really really appreciate
that you Bros check out the game
(emotional music)
It means you support me and what I do
and that really means something to me
and that you're willing to
spend a little money for
for something like this
I really appreciate that
and I'm not taking that
by any means for granted
I really really really do appreciate it!
And-
The app got on the top list
of iOS
and Google Play
Which is amazing!
It really shows the power of you Bros
This- I'm not a tmartn trying to manipulate my fans
(Chuckles and laughs)
I really mean it!
It's really cool
I- Ive- Ive- Ive-
Okay (music stops)
That went on way too long thank you very much
lets keep going and thank you
Thank you
Lets talk to Pewdiebot!
PewDiePie talks to Pewdiebot!
Lets go
Hey PewDiePie.
"How's it going Bro?"
Sounds just like me!
For those of you who wonder
how
we did it so that it's my voice
I bascially
had to record
a ton of material
And I had to read out setences like this:
"I buy three apples."
"I felt quite moved."
"In less than four days-
his deadline passed."
"He gave me a cuddle."
"Please take him off."
"Tears will not help."
(creepy echo) "She desired nothing more."
(Increases voice) "Our people ware hungry for peace."
(Very loud & disorted) "WE WANT TO ENSURE THEY B-"
I had to do this for hours
and hours
It was worth it
I would do it again
I- Ive visited
Insanity
and ive come back from that
That's what that experience was like
So I'm sure you've noticed
If you mention some references
I'll respond accordingly
Backflip
I think this is an Easter Egg
"*frontflip*! EGG004"
Yes!
Keep tweeting me
if you find the easter eggs
There's a lot of them still missing!
A lot!
The majority are still missing.
Maybe we made it a little too hard
Fist my anus
"What age are you?"
That is a valid question!
(Laughing)
(Ominous music)
Oh my god what the fuck did you smoke?
"What if I told you that every hour, there is a 4:20 in the world."
(Intense music)
Holy shit!
Oh my god and his eyes lit up with it!
"I don't smoke but Edgar is pretty baked!"
(Chuckles)
Eyyyy
We got Edgar
"Who are you exactly!?!"
(Chuckles)
Oh? You're asking me that?
I'm the real pewdiepie (poodiepie)
"What are you?"
The real PewDiePie (poodiepie)
"Say my name!"
FUCK YOU
ASSHOLE
"Where is peiwdiepie?"
You can't- don't even know how to spell your own name!
You're a fake!
I'm the real poodiepie!
"I the real Pewdiepie, or at least I'm the smartestest pewdiepie?!"
You're the "smartestest" pewdiepie?
Fuck you
I didn't even write that so-
Basically- oh god-
The bot learns from what you Bros tell him
So if you keep saying certain things
I'll pick up on it
Some stuff are scripted
Some stuff are random
and some stuff is just completely nonsense
(Chuckles)
"I'm the real Pewdiepie,
the other one is a fake!"
No!
Hey!
Hey! Hey! Hey!
Don't listen to him!
DON'T LISTEN TO HIM!
I'm the real poodiepie!
I'M THE REAL POODIEPIE!
We look very-
Very similar right now
We were making the game while I had the beard
And we were like should I have the beard or not
(Chuckles)
I kinda went back
Ok
Whatever
Alright
"I'm pewdiepie!"
Ok, fuck you!
"Lol you got pranked!"
Ooohhhh!
Hey speak swedish, can you do that?
"Jag har små ballar!"
(Laughing)
Oh-
I forgot I had-
I have tiny balls
(Chuckles)
I think he can say more stuff in Swedish
"Kou ack ack ack ack kaa."
(Laughing)
(Rock music)
(Rock music) Kou!
(childrens song) ♪ Kou ack ack ack, Kou ack ack ack,
Kou ack ack ack ack kaa. ♪
Take it Pewdiebot!
Pewdiebot: "Kou ackackackackack,
kou ackackackack."
(blows kiss)
(blows another kiss)
What a great singer
Do you like markiplier?
"Hello everybody!
Muricaplier-
Here! *BroFist!*"
Muricaplier! (laughing)
Edgar
"It's DEUTSCHLAND!!"
DEUTSCHLAND!
(Chuckles)
"I love Maya,
but Edgar is satan."
Well a- he ain't lying bout that
Alright bye
"Stay awesome bro!"
Stay awesome bro!
(Cringing) OOOOOO-
K!
We're gonna keep updating it!
Keep looking for easter eggs Bros
I really- and
tweet them at me
If you can find them
I love it that you Bros tweet me the conversations
that you have as well
there's some really really funny ones
Ah- and I really enjoy reading those
You'll be able to talk to me in your own language
Which is really cool
I think
Don't want to promise too much
But there will be more!
Thank you everyone
So much for supporting this!
(Screen disorting / Teleportation effect)
Eh- stop! stop right there!
Stop right- there!
Pewds from the future here
I got an announcement to make
Now- I think we've-
we've made a mistake
And I'm here to correct it
Pewdiebot is Free!
It's free!
You guys can check it out
even if you got it
pewdiebot.com
Now everyone can play with it
The reason why we put a price on the bot
was because
we knew the servers
would be completely fucked
if we just opened the Hellgates
But now that the first wave
is kind of gone
I feel that we can hande it and-
To be honest
We really wanted it to be free
from the begining
A lot of you Bros have been requesting it
and it feels like the right way to have it
It does have Ads on it
and doesn't include the easter eggs
That's still only for the app versions
So only if you have the app you can find the easter eggs
I love seeing you Bros reaction to this game
And-
Please keep sending then to me
It's so funny to read all the conversations
That you have with Pewdiebot
And yeah!
I hope you have fun with it!
I think- It's a really really cool thing
And I just wanna say
Huge thanks!
From the bottom of my heart
That
To everyone
That supported the Pewdiebot
And- and got the app
I thought it was so cool to see
That it got on the top list of sales
And-
I really really do appreciate that you Bros support-
That kind of stuff that
I make
And put out there
It- It does mean a lot to me
So yeah!
Thanks again!
And-
I'll see you Bros
When the next video
And as always-
Stay awesome Bros! *BroFist!*
"Just looking at myself like that
is terrifying!"
"He have great hair though
it looks very nice."
"Hey don't smile back at that! (Chuckles)"
sub to me deathcheater lollllollolololl